le ministre de l'éducation nationale
avait été lui-même sur le terrain à la
première heure ce matin dès l'ouverture
des portes à l'école communale
d'elancourt dans les yvelines
il s'est ensuite rendu dans un collège
de versailles le souci prioritaire de
jean pierre chevènement
c'est l'échec scolaire comme il a
expliqué antenne de miti vous souvenez
d'autre part au cours de l'heure de
vérité laurent fabius avait insisté sur
l'importance de la formation des jeunes
en souhaitant un jumelage entre l'école
et l'entreprise
ce qu'en pense jean pierre chevènement
au micro de dominique laurens je pense
que je peux être très utilisée lors que
l'école assure aux jeunes une bonne
formation de base et où j'ai rencontré
les syndicats les patrons et j'ai
entendu un discours
curieusement semblables ce que demande y
compris la délégation du cnpf que j'ai
reçu c'est une meilleure formation de
base que les élèves qui quittent le
système scolaire sache d'abord parler le
français et une fois ceux-ci réaliser on
peut en effet rapproché des
établissements surtout des
établissements du technique et sur les
priorités du gouvernement ou des
collèges et puis d'autre part des
entreprises pourquoi parce que
l'éducation nationale doit intervenir
dans la formation permanente par la
formation des jeunes et en particulier
parce qu'on appelle la formation
alternée c'est à dire des stages tantôt
à l'entreprise
tentons à l'école le président de la
république a résumé cela par une formule
à l'entreprise n'est pas l'enfer et
l'école n'est pas le cocon je crois que
l'une et l'autre ont tout à gagner à
mieux se connaître et en même temps
naturellement ça permettra de donner
aux jeunes qui sortent du système
éducatif les formations réglementaires
qui leur permettront d'accéder plus
facilement à un métier